la economía en directo américa ya está
lista en el estudio daniela a blandón
dan y bienvenidas feliz mañana del
jueves
comenzamos con atención en españa' por
las declaraciones del presidente
mexicano sobre su relación económica
principalmente daniela claro round muy
buenos días si usted que es medio
español como siempre lo digo debe saber
que el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador pues siempre ha tratado de
que españa se disculpe son los pueblos
nativos de este país por los abusos
cometidos durante la conquista esta vez
trató de defenderse de las críticas a
sus proyectos de privilegiar a las
empresas estatales en proyectos
energéticos apuntando a empresas como
iberdrola y repsol como aquellas que se
han beneficiado abusivamente dice de
gobiernos anteriores escuchamos lo
antes eran como dueños de méxico es el
caso de las empresas españolas
que ahora no es buena en la relación y a
mí me gustaría
qué
este hasta nos tardamos
en que se normalizará a hacer una pausa
que yo creo que nos va a convenir
a los mexicanos y a los españoles pues
la respuesta española no se hizo esperar
raúl el canciller josé manuel álvarez
dijo que no se ha hecho nada que pueda
justificar una declaración de este tipo
y que lo que sí está claro es que lejos
de detenerse los flujos de inversión
binacional sólo han aumentado durante
años bueno alguien la vamos a ver
entonces qué pasa el presidente obrador
nuevamente de alguna manera como
arremetiendo contra españa pero nosotros
vamos a américa porque el paro de
caminar es en canadá se está haciendo
sentir en la industria automotriz
daniela claro y ya hay dos
multinacionales ford y toyota que
dijeron que van a suspender parte de su
producción como consecuencia de este
bloqueo en el puente ambassador y es que
esta es la ruta principal del suministro
para la boyante industria
automovilística estadounidense en
detroit que es el corazón histórico de
este sector cada día lo atraviesan unos
8.000 camiones con mercancías por 323
millones de dólares el cierre del puente
ya provoca una escasez de piezas en la
planta de montaje del fabricante de
vehículos este antes en windsurf
que tuvo que reducir sus horarios
también
se habla sobre los estantes vacíos de
las tiendas de comestibles sobre las
interrupciones en las cadenas de
suministros la realidad es que en este
momento las personas en weezer están
sufriendo y perdiendo sus trabajos
porque no pueden obtener autopartes que
pasan por el puente ambas salud y este
partido conservador que apoya esos
bloqueos ni siquiera se levanta y dice
basta es hora de irse a casa y este paro
se suma también a la crisis de
suministros de microchips y todo pues va
a ser una bola de nieve de daniela pero
venimos ahora a nuestra región porque la
inflación comenzó el año disparada en
toda américa latina bueno ya hemos
venido diciendo que durante 2021 la
constante fue el aumento de precios en
toda la región en todo el mundo también
y pues así lo demuestran los datos de
los países que han reportado en los
últimos días que 2022 también inició con
precios altos en venezuela el banco
central ya está volviendo a publicar y
dijo que en enero la inflación fue del
67 por ciento pero la cifra más
relevante suele ser la interanual es
decir raúl los últimos 12 meses cuanto
está hoy el producto frente
un año atrás y en este caso la inflación
supera el 472 por ciento en venezuela el
gobierno dice que el fenómeno de
hiperinflación ya es asunto del pasado
nos vamos a mina brasil donde la
inflación acumulada hasta enero fue del
10 38 por ciento en chile fue del 77 por
ciento y en méxico del 7,07 por ciento
en enero muy cerca del máximo histórico
de noviembre pasado vamos ahora a ver
entonces los indicadores danny pues
hablando de inflación hoy se va a
conocer el dato de inflación de eeuu muy
importante para todo el mundo en general
los mercados están bastante expectantes
y cerraron al alza en el caso de asia
los analistas esperan esperan que en
enero la inflación interanual se haya
disparado a su máximo en cuatro décadas
las acciones europeas también operan al
alza aunque con ganancias tímidas y
vamos ahora a ver la cifra del día que
nos sirve para hoy raúl usted ha ido a
los parques temáticos de disney yo creo
que fue cuando tenía siete años pero eso
es una cita pendiente que tengo que
hacer porque me encantan bueno yo he ido
como tres veces y las tres veces de
llorado
pues mira las cifras son los 21.000 820
millones de dólares los ingresos de
disney que volvió a ganancias en el
trimestre que terminó en enero en sus
ingresos crecieron 34% y es que los casi
12 millones de suscriptores a disney más
en estos tres meses y el regreso también
masivo de turistas a los parques
temáticos dieron brillo a sus resultados
financieros que en pandemia recordemos
se habían visto fuertemente golpe a la
magia de disney daniela muchísimas
gracias por toda la información más
adelante más economía vamos a pasar a
ver nuestro reportaje